[Music]
thank you very much everyone for being
here and today you will learn about how
to remember what you learn and you will
and to have also speak about the
essential Python libraries for your
first data science project and some and
actually the fundamental partner streaks
so as to deal with let's say large-scale
data so the first problem that I faced
when started learning about machine
learning was that I couldn't remember
the derivatives but I have spent so much
time in high school trying to to learn
about calculus so why this happened why
this happened yeah because learning is
not an instant thing it demands by your
brain to store the new piece of
information or behavior in this case the
gradients in the long term memory so
sometimes happens something like this so
the forgetting curve is one one theory
from cognitive psychology that helps us
to explain why learning is hard so what
it is what is it the forgetting curve
the forgetting curve tells us that
through time since your first your for
the first time that you interacted with
a new knowledge component let's say
derivatives since the first night time
this know let's tend to decay over time
exponentially and here we can see the
formula so the Y represents your if you
are able to recall these informations
let's say derivatives T represents the
time since you first studied this
information so we call this lug and H is
really important it we call this
half-life and it tells us what is the
strong what is the strength in long-term
memory of derivatives so when this curve
is flat this means that I've just
practiced derivative so it's still fresh
in my mind
but what should I do now
how to fool the forgetting curve so as
to remember the derivatives from now on
so one technique is actually one one one
model is called spaced repetition
repetition because I have to repeatedly
repeatedly test my test myself on
derivatives in space because this
repetition should be instead of mass
should we spread it over time and here
we can here we can see the forgetting
curve here it is the first recall of
derivatives and we can see that because
of the forgetting curves one recall
isn't enough one recall of the
derivative so I have to make many
Oracle's over time so as to remember
what I learned after a long period of
time but the next interesting question
is how many times should I do this
review of derivatives like forever and
then I found two the two most famous
spaced repetition models which which are
used especially in linguistics domain
and these are called pimp insulin system
and Leitner system let's take a look at
the first one the interval that it takes
are fixed so like after five seconds
after 25 seconds and then after two
years if you are able to recall what you
the derivatives in this case then this
is going to be stored in your long-term
memory the second model the lightener
system is a bit more adaptive why
because instead of just using fixed
intervals and between my reviews it says
okay I will decrease or increase the
interval based on your performance based
on if you would if you were able to
correctly recall derivatives or not and
it's time I recorded the derivatives
then it helps it's yeah it's it's it has
the increase their intervals whereas
each time that I incorrectly recall it's
the
was it that's all good Denise but then
then I said are there any data available
outside there so as to see if I can if I
could get rid of these hand pick
parameters and see if I could use real
data of students so as to see what works
and what doesn't
or even take even take one step further
and try to find is there any online
lending platform that already make use
of this model so as to improve to share
the learner for don't forget what he
tries to learn and I found something I
found blue lingo duolingo is an online
learning platform which is used by many
students around the global when they
want to learn a new language yeah and
what it does it generalizes the two
previous model models the lightener and
then the pincer and how does it do that
with half life regression and here we
can see two examples of how how does
rolling who uses it so every time that I
practice now not the derivatives but a
new wart in a new language let's say
dots I can I can I am able to see how
strong is yeah feel Blizzard in my mind
is it still strong in my mind this what
or is it is going to overdo so I'm going
to forget the next time how to say have
fun to my colleagues another example
besides the memory progress bars another
it also uses the half life the half life
regression so as to recommend me what
kind of words sued a review before this
overdue so instead of trying to unlock
the new the new skill which in this case
is measures maybe I should consider to
make a review for what I have learned up
to now but the next yeah last question
is how harsh life regression works so
half life regression tries to
well it combines forgetting curve with
basic machine learning techniques so as
to find the bind the boundary between
the correct recall and the incorrect
recall and here we because we are going
to this is the first data science
project of a potential data scientist
the first that we should know is that
every machine learning model every even
if it is something super technical like
deep learning every machine learning
model contains three components we have
to build a model namely what kind of
data are important and what is the model
structure we have to train the model so
how to optimize the function that I'm
trying to optimize and how to test to
see how this work with data that my
algorithm never seen before how to
predict so let's see how low half life
regression characterizes yeah let's go
let's dive into the first step to build
the model and let's see how harsh life
regression characterizes the human
learning in this case in this case yeah
so here we can see the data that we use
for half life regression so in total we
have four features so before we are able
to predict the future we have to see
what is the past and here we can see a
fit actually here we can see the
previous exposure of a learner with the
world so how many times he had a correct
recall how many times wrong recall and
actually how often does he or she
interacts with this specific words and
the lexemes rig actually is a word but
it has got the it has got it is attached
to part of speed stacks the Leamas
morphological features so this is
account the content feature related and
the other theory are considered the
interaction features of the users and to
total we have more than a hundred
thousand of students on to two thousand
words and both these two okay
and each data is here we can see an
example of the data instances and teach
data insist represent the the correct
recall so we have got labels for our
data we know if someone would be able in
the future to correctly recall the word
that the T which is the lag time when
that did you start practicing this word
the half-life which is super important
for our algorithm the user ID and the
lexeme ID so and now I'm going to
introduce the first most basic data
science library which is the one used
here as well and also it is going to be
used yet to explore our data but what I
would what we care ok
firstly let me say that pandas is the
most basic library most probably well
now that so as to manipulate the data
import and export and import CSV data
through or export and to use we do that
with data frames and when we have
large-scale data there are some tricks
that could help us to improve the
performance of a low offer algorithm and
here we can see that with read CSV with
the read CSV method I can pick for the
parameter called sang size so as to load
my data into different tags instead of
loading them all at once
what I miss to say is that in total we
have got 313 million
traces of student yeah 13 million and
now we upload them by 10,000 yeah
another method that I could use is is
called dot info and this one he can
gives us information about what kind of
columns do our data have what data types
are this data and how many days this is
have I got totally and C and after I do
that it's pretty important to also drop
the columns that my model isn't going to
use so as to not take them into our code
and and another method is called as type
so it's important to for performance
reasons is important to convert our
float or int integers from thirty sixty
four-bit
to thirty-two I cannot and I can already
show you how now let me give me a minute
and I can already show you how memory
efficient is this so here you can see
that I am using data yeah the command
Adachi
info so us to see the columns of my data
and they datatypes and I can all I can
observe that most of them are of float64
or integer 64 and after and it consumes
a memory uses of 1.1 gigabytes and after
that after I convert them to float 32 I
can already see a big difference in to
my memory usage in these gates 800
megabytes so let let me go back to the
presentation ah without seeing my note
yeah so now that you are convinced that
these simple methods have got super
useful parameters another really useful
libraries called matplotlib it's really
useful because this is the usually the
straightforward library that we are
going to use for data plots and
exploration of your data or the
distribution of the features if you want
to get an insight of what kind of data
do you have and this is for the first
step for how to build the model how to
see what kind of data do we have and now
let's move forward into the model
structure the more the structure of half
life regression and remember that the
half regression is the exponential
exponential factor function and here
it's time I actively recorrect I
actively recall a specific word I see
that this also exponentially increases
so here we can see yeah the formula that
we've already seen and what hard for
aggregation does in addition to that is
that it tries to fit it tries to
optimize also towards the half life
regression so how strong this is into my
memory this word and this is important
because I should revise it exactly at
the point that my mind is almost going
to forget it so when you are at this
edge you should recall it and here we
can see this the red dashed line
represents the estimated decimated
models that tries to minimize the
distance between the observed recall
rates because it's a supervised learning
problem yeah and what I didn't say is
that for half-life since we have we we
assume an exponential growth we have we
see the exponential function of the
weights are all multiplied with the
features weights or parameters so the
second step is to train our model and to
violate this as as we've seen and most
specifically the common choice for a
regression model it's a asked a cost or
negative function is the squared loss
function so what we want to do is to
minimize the difference between the
estimated values and the real values and
we do that with trying to optimize the
squared loss function and because the
parameter the parameter space is somehow
big I should find a way to deal with the
overfitting problem what is that that is
when our model just memory memorizes the
data instances and the scent of trying
in the scent of finding the true
function of the model just memorizes the
data instances and that makes it unable
to predict for data in statistics that
has never seen before and I'm and we are
doing that with Reid's regression which
is this regularization term here which
penalizes the weights of the features
but but but how can I learn the feature
if the weights for the features so to
learn the weights for the fit so we will
use gradient descent which is widely
used in machine learning and it is it is
yeah used for minimizing differential
functions with many parameters so my
friend calculus again and it is used to
yeah to find the gradient of the cost
function and update the values for the
parameters with a simple update rule and
on this point we should make two
decisions what should be the learning
rate so the size of the change of the
parameter value values and here an
advice is not use a super big learning
rate because it's going to surpass the
optimization points but neither is super
small learning great because it it is
going to be super slow and the second
decision that I have to make to the
optimization part is what portion of
training examples are going to be used
to update the values all of them at once
or in batches so how to predict in data
for data that my mother has never seen
before
how to evaluate so acid evaluation
metrics we use the quantitative one of
the mean absolute error - yeah to
quantify how close the predictions were
with the real virus and to qualitative
ones the Spearman rank correlation which
measures the statistical dependence
between the real and estimated one and
the other one is the ROC curve which
yeah measures the ability of the
algorithm to distinguish the real curve
the they correct from the ink electrical
rates and that's also and another
example for where when you we use MATLAB
matplotlib so yeah plot this parameter
yeah so the third the third library is
called scikit-learn
library and we used it so as to for to
implement machine learning calgary's so
the code for the half life regression by
duolingo is is built by scraps so with
pure python which is pretty nice but
it's not it's not super flexible and you
cannot yeah play with model selection
stuff so instead of building all this
math stuff from the beginning it would
be nice to use scikit-learn for for the
machine learning calendar we want to
implement but before doing that we have
to convert our data frames into vectors
and matrices because this is how machine
learning models work so numpy is the
library from Nampa we should use nd we
yeah
nd array which is yeah for fast and
space-efficient will multi multi
dimensional array and we can use
vectorized factions instead of loops
which is more efficient and in this may
be at this point i the the problem that
I at least faced while I was starting
learning machine learning is that all
all the errors that I received wasn't
about how how the flow of the machine
learning model or the data center
science project where but
there's were broadcasting errors so well
I I didn't use them I didn't follow the
correct broadcasting yet principles that
not numpy implements so as to yeah
to make the operations between yeah
vectors and matrices to work correctly
yeah and then in sake scikit-learn has
already got and implemented a function
which is called because it's a linear
regression model so we can find it in
the linear model and se the sense for
suhasi gradient descent and down we can
see yeah but which we can opt for the
loss so in this case squared loss we can
opt for the penalty so the
regularization term the one who is going
to penalize the way it's the Alpha is
the one who is going to put importance
how we pointed this half life into this
objective function and the learning rate
so how fast should gradient be updated
and another the the fifth and the last
library is the site by the last
fundamental library this scifi and
provides us with statistical functions
and in this case provides us the
Spearman correlation magic so so yeah
now maybe I should say something about
what are the best practices while you
are building your machine learning code
for model so what is it is considered as
a good good practice is to firstly
define the model structure so like the
data inputs and the hyper parameter
values then as a second step it will
initialize the model parameters in this
case in linear regression it doesn't so
much matter if you're going to randomly
initialize the weights but in neural
networks in matters how do you
initialize your parameter your
parameters and the third step is yeah to
calculate the loss as we saw the square
loss yeah to calculate the gradient and
to update the parameters with the
gradient descent and all of the and
three steps integrated him to one one
function and usually we'll call this one
model in this case space repetition
model and what is important another not
best practice but most like an advice
regarding yeah regarding machine
learning is that we should always stop
in debug always duds ourselves always
say that what is the case is that this
model is going to fail it doesn't going
to work so let's be critical and I wish
to do that before before accepting that
this model should go into production
should be implemented into my learning
on online learning platform why because
if it's over if it over fits then it's
going to what happened in this case that
users were super frustrated because it's
despite how how long they would practice
some words would decay rapidly and that
was an overfitting problem
despite - I used despite yeah there was
there was used regularization so
regularization is not always enough and
specifically the the lexeme tanks led to
overfitting yeah so since we're speaking
about yeah but since we are talking
about how to remember what you learn and
you can be nice to leave this room by
just remembering at least one thing
don't be hard with yourself just
remember all you are think from this
SIG's so let's begin with the first one
how do do we start we started that it's
difficult to remember to learn new
things and forgetting curve is theory
tells us that okay it's all about time
and memory strength of this of this
knowledge unit of this of this behavior
that you are trying to reign okay how
can I fool you I can fool you by using
space repetition model okay what is this
about this is all about time and review
revision is boring but it's effective
the third is what is half-life
regression okay's a linear regression
model but what is it about it it's all
about the forgetting care linking the
forgetting curve so a cognize
of science theory with machine learning
techniques and simple machine learning
things in this case the fourth one is
okay since I'm new in data science what
what is machine learning machine
learning is always composed by three
things how to represent my problem and
my day and what are my data are
representative for this problem
optimization I'm trying to optimize this
function I'm trying to find what this
function is and to always evaluate in to
test later into data that your algorithm
has never seen hasn't trained before on
that data the fifth is the Dover feed in
which sometimes is most of the times is
yeah rig is yeah uuugh we use
regularization so as to yeah to overcome
it but we should always diagnose before
production and the basic fundamental
libraries for any machine learning model
is the SyFy for statistical stuff the
numpy for doing vectorization and
converting our data to vectors scalar
for using different data sets they play
around and using already built already
built models many models pandas so was
to explore my data and to import or
export yeah data instead of using the
CSV reader like playing Python and much
blow Lib for or Seabourn maybe if you
prefer better yeah visualizations so and
I will end this table with some
questions beside these days takes awake
the questions are first of all features
is the most important thing in every
machine learning model and we can
already see that into the hackathons and
into yeah meneka hackathons but usually
the machine learning models are not the
most difficult and complex ones are but
they are the ones which we that have got
have done nice feature engineering car
yeah things so in this case for memory
decay maybe a suit also you
user feedback so as to see because in
the beginning the forgetting curve
Dentsu always recommends you the same
words so as to verify that these you
know this word but users get to get
frustrated so it would be nice to say
okay don't saw me this again please I've
mastered it also to use more generic
content features because previously we
saw that actually it was the lik syntax
that led to overfitting and by by
broader like syntax yeah I yeah yeah I
mean yeah less less dense yeah but and
another another maybe interesting
feature since we are speaking about
let's say now languages is a similarity
between the native and the learning
language if I'm trying to learn dots and
my native language is Greek is going to
be much more difficult if then to be
then for my native now in the language
to towards let's say German because they
have more similarities these two
language between yeah another
interesting thing is that all we we
always observe in learning car yeah I
non line learning happening these things
but this thing that we assume in
dependency but this domain is highly
dependent and in this cake the reviews
are always dependent with the content
and between the review and the reviews
between them the second question has to
do with quantitative domains like that
one of statistics or of linear algebra
up to now we've seen the spaced
repetition model to be applied in to
linguistics modular linguistics domains
and we assume that this hasn't happened
before in quantitative domains because
space repetition demands requires for
its piece of knowledge to be really
really fine grained like like in the
form of a flashcard and linear algebra
for example is really difficult to do
that because everything like derivatives
is usually highly interdependent with
yeah with let's say differential
functions and the third and the most
important one which is the ultimate goal
is how to
optimize human learning in this case in
online learning environments because
we've already seen a big wave of users
just using online learning platforms to
learn something news so the the old
among God is how to make revision fun
and know and not let our users to quit I
can I don't have much time to show the
demo but yeah rent is that we hope in
the future that machine learning is
going to help to improve online learning
as well despite other yeah more
technical domains so that's my
presentation thank you
[Applause]